[Music]
when scrolling youtube
you may have stumbled across the
occasional nursery rhyme channel
they promised lighthearted songs and
innocent fun
perfect for small children and their
exhausted parents
these channels have amassed a huge
number of views
this one in particular has over 100
million subscribers
and is set to become the largest on the
site
but lurking behind these playful songs
lie
dark and disturbing backstories rhymes
believed to about the plague
slavery and in one instance burying
someone alive
but do they have any historical truth
behind them or are they simply
urban legends meant to frighten and
entertain
let's take a look at the gruesome and
grim origins behind our beloved
children's songs
and separate the fact from the folklore
as we delve into the dark side
of nursery rhymes we start with a
familiar one
a classic childhood staple
black sheep have you ever yes sir
yes sir three bags full one for the
master
[Music]
at face value this is a song about sheep
and wool
right well the controversy surrounding
this nursery rhyme began in the late 80s
and 90s when it was connected to slavery
in the american south proponents of this
view argue the following
the black sheep is a reference to the
african descent of american slaves
the three bags full of wool reflects the
cotton that slaves were forced to
collect in large bags
and the master sheep relationship is
reminiscent of master's slave language
this perceived connection has led
schools to change the song's title
to bar bar rainbow sheep to disassociate
it from slavery
however many experts believe that the
song actually has nothing to do with
slavery
nor even america instead the song is
believed to have originated in britain
the first written record of this song is
from an english nursery rhyme book
called tom thumb's pretty song book it
was written in 1744
and is the oldest surviving collection
of english nursery rhymes out there
it's older than the declaration of
independence and so
technically predates america itself that
said
slavery was still widespread whilst
america was a british colony
nowadays people believe the song came
from the middle ages
originating with the medieval tax on the
wool trade
known as the great wool tax it was set
up by edward the first
who needed extra money to pay for the
crusades a series of brutal conflicts in
the holy land
under these new laws english wool was
heavily taxed
a third of a bag's price went to the
king another went to the church
and a final third went to the farmer
thus
one for the master being the king one
for the dame
is the church the so-called bride of
christ
and one for the little boy who lives
down the lane the farmers
so instead of being a rhyme about the
slave trade barbar black sheep is a
medieval song
about the money made from the heavy
taxation of wool
that was used later to fund the mass
murder and slaughter of the crusades
perhaps a stretch but nonetheless dark
ok
moving on this nursery rhyme is also
attested in the song book from 1744.
you'll be familiar with the lyrics they
go as follows
[Music]
now this nursery rhyme has a handful of
dark origins
but which one of them is the most
plausible
an early explanation for the song came
from samuel lang in 1844
he believed that the song describes a
viking raid
specifically olaf ii of norway who
allegedly pillaged the town of london
in 1014. the north saga
heims kringler has this strange verse
london bridge is broken down
gold is one and bright renown shields
resounding
war horns sounding hild is shouting in
the din
arrow singing male coats ringing odin
makes our olaf win
lang believes that this skuldic verse
was the basis of our nursery rhyme today
but from the perspective of the poor
londoners left to rebuild it
experts argue that this translation of
the old norse has been made to fit
around the nursery rhyme and thus
takes a lot of liberties in the
translation so
whilst london bridge was likely raided
by the vikings at some point in history
it was unlikely to have been the basis
for this nursery rhyme
this next theory is far darker some
speculate
that the song is all about london bridge
and how people were buried alive
within its foundations so back in the
day
there was this punishment known as
immune a grisly practice where people
sometimes even children were buried
alive within walls
the folklorist alice bertha gom believed
that this story was within the nursery
rhyme itself
she homed in on the line take the keys
and lock her up
somewhere later in the poem and took it
as a possible link to the immune
practice but unfortunately for her
no skeletons of adults nor children have
ever been unearthed in the foundations
of london bridge
so we can discount this theory for now
okay
this third theory is the most likely
candidate
it goes back to the idea that the bridge
was destroyed a handful of times
but just not by the vikings records show
that in 1209
king john ordered london bridge be built
now it may have existed before then
perhaps stretching all the way back to
roman occupation
this new medieval bridge was made from
stone
but with that it brought its own
challenges over time
shopkeepers and residents began to
construct buildings on top of the stone
foundations
and the bridge soon became very cramped
and in such close quarters
fires spread fast a few years later in
1212
the first fire broke out on both ends
with many bridge dwellers trapped in the
center
years later it was rebuilt only to be
destroyed again
in two separate uprisings one in 1381
and one in 1450 in both cases the bridge
was rebuilt but
as you may have guessed it burnt down
again in 1633
at this point it was left partially
unbuilt just in time for the great fire
of london
in 1666 no surprise why the song
london bridge is falling down came about
shortly after
the bridge was in a constant state of
disrepair owing largely to those houses
built upon it
is an amusing commentary on this
seemingly cursed structure
no viking raids or bearing alive this
time
another famous nursery rhyme but also
famously dark
bring your ring
[Music]
many folklorists have connected it to
the great plague
but how those last two lines where
children sneeze and fall down
are seen as a veiled reference to those
dying from the plague
the plague in question being the great
plague of london in 1666
the same year if you recall as the great
fire of london
bad year it was an outbreak of bubonic
plague an epidemic
that killed an estimated 100 000 people
the death toll of the great plague is
dwarfed by the black death a few
centuries prior
it's believed that the black death
outbreak of 1346
to 1353 killed an estimated 75 million
to 200 million people it was the most
lethal pandemic of all time
and led to the development of the grim
reaper but that's the topic of another
video
factoring a roses according to legend
children began to dance and sing
around the corpses of the infected dead
and mockingly sing this song
an incredibly disturbing and gruesome
legend were it to be true
it isn't it's only until the mid 20th
century
until folklore start coming up with this
plague story about ringer roses
before then no such legend existed the
song only appears in english song books
in 1881 so if the song did originate in
the 17th century
or even in the middle ages as some
speculate one would expect to see it
written down
much earlier now if we wish to get
scientific and go further
then the symptoms of the plague don't
even match up with a nursery rhyme
the bacterium responsible for the
bubonic plague yesina pestis
was transferred via rats not sneezing as
in the song
instead the main symptoms of the plague
were these large
uncomfortable warts called buboes hence
the name eubonic plague
the infected would also experience
nausea vomiting
and fever but sneezing is not one of
them
so if it didn't originate with the
plague where is it from
well it's still a mystery in fact many
believe that the song didn't even
originate in england
but may have come from europe or america
the thing is
with so many variations of this nursery
rhyme it becomes hard and harder to
locate its true origin
some of the oldest versions come from
america so the song
may have originated there this version
from texas for example
in 1939 has no perceivable connection to
death at
all
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
i say all this but even if the song
isn't about the play
it somehow still feels creepy
the same is true for all the nursery
rhymes discussed in the video
it begs the question why are nursery
rhymes so inherently dark
one of the most frightening things is
when something safe or childlike
is revealed as evil and dark the trope
has a name
subverted innocence we see it all the
time in horror movies
the demonic orphan in the omen the
possessed toy chucky in child's play
and the child eating clown pennywise
from it
nursery rhymes are another example of
subverted innocents
they are warped into having frightening
and disturbing origins
some indeed do but many don't it seems
that we humans are magnetically
attracted to the macabre
by projecting our own dark fears about
the past onto nursery rhymes
we open a pandora's box and discover
their disturbing potential
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this video as much as i
enjoyed making it
do let me know in the comments of other
dark nursery rhymes worth exploring
fairy tales too i might wish to return
to this topic in a series of future
videos
and whilst you're here why not subscribe
a like and a comment
also go a really long way and help the
channel to grow
i look forward to seeing you next time
goodbye
you